[Music]
anyway let's get on to the cart girls
tick tock
because we said we were into this last
time we didn't do it uh
this is this is well let's let the
explaining
one explain for us okay
listen up the three most popular places
where business gets done
are restaurants strip clubs and golf
courses these are also
the places where we can make the best
tips all right let me explain
businessmen come here to plex okay they
came here ready to spend
they're most likely using a company card
and they're going to write it off anyway
so don't be afraid to wrap that thing up
if they want to buy their new business
partner a drink unless they specifically
ask for the wealth
wow
how's their partner gonna feel if they
see you pour the cheap stuff in versus
if you pour the top shelf stuff in
the one paying is probably gonna feel
pretty stupid if you knew a four dollar
difference for the shot is coming
between him and business
so you gotta help them out so it's been
five hours and we're leaving with 538
dollars which isn't bad for a thursday
500 bucks she made in tips
holy [ __ ] hey i'm gonna be a car girl
yeah you should not be twitch streaming
you should be a cart girl
yeah i'm learning here seriously can we
do a cart girl twitch let's create that
that can be the new category on twitch
park car you just gave that away delete
that
[Laughter]
that's the new twitch meta yeah you know
we're gonna contract um
someone to give us long hair we need
long hair if we're going to be cart
girls yeah i don't know could you be a
bald car girl yeah you could
yeah you could rock bald yeah you got to
be a baddie though
yeah that part we don't have down some
face tats or something like that you
know
oh i'll get like a tattoo like a knife
on the back yes yes that's what i'm
talking about something
you gotta be a little bit goth yeah
eyeliner and a sword going down the back
of my neck yeah
and then a couple rings yeah there you
go
yeah so did you guys want tequila
[Laughter]
what's up robby your cart girl today sub
i'm noelle i'm your cart girl
yeah cart boys yeah what about cart boys
are there powerful business women that
want what's up homies
i'll be your car boy today i'm cody of
course
good to meet you fellas what'll it be
what are y'all having yeah
are there any cart men
oh no yeah
no for sure nah sorry just car boys here
card voice sounds like none of them are
taller than five
all short all annoying just frat dudes
yeah
basically ladies
we have nothing nothing please leave we
brought our own alcohol
that's actually not not allowed it's
against course policy ooh i'm going to
write you up
it's just like the meter maid of the
golf course yeah
but for the right presidential
combination i may
just let it slide so i don't have a 5.
what is up guys it is uh i'm here to
breathalyze all of you
with my lips
get him out of here no no no he's trying
to kiss the golfing
business women again no i wasn't it was
a joke it was a joke
i was like a more just like shitty mall
cop just like making sure people are
abiding by the course rules
not like that just frat boy horrible
pickup line what's up i'm here to
breathalyze you guys let's taste
oh i see alcohol is that alcohol i see
i'm gonna come back around i better not
see
anything or somebody's wearing metal
all right tell us more about let's let's
see another cart girl let's see another
one what else you know what she had
no this is like points i was like kind
of waiting to make fun of this but like
it kind of makes total sense she said
about the nicer alcohol
it's a great house i've never done
business on a golf course before i
i'm waiting to get to that point in life
where that becomes a thing
but it so far hasn't happened you know
yeah there's not a lot of golfing in
podcasting
no we could
this guy dropped a hundred dollar bill
on the ground i picked it up for him he
told me i could keep it
as long as i made sure he had ice in his
cup all day while he's out here playing
and it ended up getting really hot and
he left early
so i only had to fill his cup like twice
but
sorry i can't control the weather and i
must be on a lucky streak today because
this other guy gave me fifty dollars he
didn't buy anything but he was like oh
i'm so sorry like last time i was here i
skipped you like you remember right and
i'm like
i don't remember that happening i don't
remember him but he's like yeah like you
remember so i had to be like
because i wanted to keep it so then his
friend said if he made his shot onto the
green from 200 yards away that he gets
my number
and he's pretty cute so i was like all
right let's see what happens he came up
with so much confidence
and then he sliced it so far right i
just had to drive away there was nothing
else to say
well it's a good day at work so okay huh
damn that that guy
is gonna leave demoralized oh yeah
especially
this she talked about it and has 5.2
million likes
and all anyone take away from that is
like so how bad did he slice it
[Laughter]
i do just try to drive away he's like i
bombed that thing i sliced the shot
so i'm just thinking about a time when i
went on a little business trip
did my little cart girl thing in miami
for a few weeks and i went by myself but
like i wanted to try a lot of the
restaurants there
so what i would do is there'd be
hundreds of guys on the golf course
every day
so i'd find a guy or like a group of
guys to invite me to dinner i know
everyone's gonna be like oh you were
just using them but shut up just shut up
because i made their night just as much
as it made mine and if they needed me to
pay for my own it wasn't like i wasn't
working every day and making my own
money so i could have
but i just wanted someone to go with and
if they want to pay for dinner hey
but after dinner i had the perfect
excuse to leave
i'd be like oh there's two times at six
tomorrow like i have to be up early i
can't stay out late i have to go to work
so it's like perfect and like for a
girls trip like i feel like that's just
such a good idea
okay so
yeah i mean is it is she the only one is
she the only cart girl
it's kind of a weird style of tick-tock
it's like vlogging
or she's doing like story times but it's
like a like little short
and story's not that great but it just
kind of seems like she's making a lot of
money and she's
yeah it's just kind of you know i think
she's just flexing off
can i say this this is this is what the
bit that we started our last podcast was
about
yeah that's what this is about yeah yeah
yeah just you know you just want that
freedom
yeah that free pretty stuff just kind of
happens you know just a free life yeah
there's just you know
things happen it's a yeah
you wish like you know what if you're a
pistol if we were pistols
we wouldn't have to say anything on this
podcast right we could just record and
be like
no that's like it's like a teenager i
think like
venice hot yeah hot venice guy okay
legs so tall like your knees are up here
okay
[Music]
but i don't know yeah it's true man i
mean you got to think about
like
[Music]
you know that that's how she feels you
know
she can take it or she can leave it i
mean it's arguable
though it's debatable no
[Music]
hey man things come and things go but
one thing that'll never happen
is it won't come back around the same
yeah i was telling my boy like
[Music]
some of them have it some of them don't
mm-hmm
exactly you can't like get caught up in
it you know it's all just about
personal growth amen bro hey man it is
as long as you're working on yourself
yeah that's bar none the most important
thing
yeah i don't know like i was [ __ ]
this chick and like
i nutted so i wanted to leave
so i got to leave and she's like really
pissed i didn't get it i was like
i thought that's what we were doing but
she's like in love with you
something like that so i had to tell her
i'm like
and love is like it takes time
that's sick yes i left
she texts me all the time i don't think
it's love yet
all right jack harlow
cartman tick tock yeah so i'm on the
green today with my
big ass nuts out i just want to say if i
if i were to do this podcast i'd be like
i would do these tick tocks if i was a
car boy yeah like so yo what's up guys
so
um i don't know must be you know bad
luck or something today because i
this guy dropped to 50 and i picked it
up for him
and he just took it back
and i was like i kind of thought maybe
because i've been you know giving him a
bunch of drinks all night
yeah you know and i was treating him
good so i kind of thought he would have
maybe
you know let me keep it but he didn't
keep it he didn't tip me at all
zero zero bucks so so that's
zero bucks today that i made off tips
yours would have three comments first
one is lol
the second one is oh sorry that happened
to you and it's a
it's like a powerpuff girl as the
profile picture and the third one is
like get more likes
click here
it's got 16 views yeah you're just
looking at your tick tock in your cart
word